reponer en contexto a los televidentes
se trata de la asamblea nacional que fue
electa en el año 2015 que ha venido
prolongando su pedido tras el
desconocimiento de las elecciones
legislativas del año 2020 en las que la
oposición venezolana no participó por
considerar que no estaban dadas las
condiciones el propio fiscal general fue
quien confirmó las órdenes de capturas
contra Dinora figuera marianela
Fernández y auristela Vázquez Quienes
fueron acusadas de usurpación de
funciones traición a la patria y
legitimación de capitales también se
emitió una alerta Roja de Interpol
contra estas ciudadanas pues no se
encuentran en Venezuela dos de ellas
están en España y otra está en Estados
Unidos El fiscal general durante la
rueda de prensa insistió en la
corrupción bajo el denominado gobierno
interino que presidía Juan guaidó y una
vez más preguntó dónde estaban todos los
recursos que ha manejado entre los años
2019 y 2023 paralelamente se conoció que
este lunes el departamento del tesoro de
Estados Unidos emitió una licencia que
permite a esta asamblea nacional
opositora controlar los activos en el
exterior como lo es si con la filial de
pedevesa en Estados Unidos y en esta
licencia se especifica que no está
permitido el control de estos activos
por parte del parlamento que preside
Jorge Rodríguez esto luego de que se
eliminara la figura del gobierno
interino que presidía Juan guaidó y se
crearan estas comisiones de la asamblea
nacional para poder continuar controlar
los activos en el exterior que no pueden
ser manejados por la administración de
Nicolás maduro tras las sanciones
impuestas a su gobierno